DEREK KINGAND A SHOT IS BLOCKED
THAT IS NOT UNCOMMON TO SEE KIRH
SHOOTING LIKE  NET.
BRUINS, IN CHICAGOE!
SAVED BY MARC-ANDRE D
PASTRNAK ON IT.
DAVID PASTRNAK .
THE FLOWER IS OUT OF HERE IN
THE LAST FEW MINUTES AWAY.
BRUINS OE AT A
COORS LIGHT FIVE PACK.THE WAY  O
BACK GAMES.
>> Eddie: THAT WAS LITTLE TRIV
>> Pat:
JONES, DROPPED IT BACK.
HERE IS STILLMAN.
HE DRIVES AND RAN T
>> Pat: RILEY, THAT IS S.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE WELL AWARE
BUT I
McAVOY.  PASTRNAK.
GOESHAWKS.
SNAPSHOT, REBOUND,O FOR A BY
BLOCK BY SEVEN.
THE BRUINSREBOUND, AND 36
MADE A SECOND SAVE! WITH
HIS LOVE, AS HE WENT THROU TO
DO, TRYING TO BE UNSELFISH TO
GET THAT Pat:  CLAVIN de HAAN SS
THE PRESSURE  FROMT.
JONES TAKES OVER.
BACK DOOR T BE
ALLOWED TO PAS BOARD.
ABLE TO COME UP WITH IT.
McCABEBE
>> Eddie: GREAT HAND I ULLMAR
HE BOUNCED INTO THE METAL.
QUICK, T
AGAIN, THE CALL ON THE ICE WAST
THE NET.
SHOT, FROM CARLY JOYAL.
CHARLIE COYLE.
CENTER, CACA .
DAVID PASTRNAK  GOT
GREAT PAST, HE